depuis le début de la crise de covile on
a vu beaucoup de scientifiques dire tout
et son contraire sur les plateaux télé
là où la professeur karine lacombe a
d'abord estimé que le port du masque à
l'extérieur ne servait à rien le
président du conseil scientifique jean
françois delfraissy a quant à lui estimé
ensuite que le port du masque à
l'extérieur aller s'imposer
évidemment de son côté didier raoult a
trouvé le moyen de mettre d'accord avec
personne
ces polémiques ont pu créer un sentiment
de confusion chez le public qui fait de
moins en moins confiance aux médecins
pour leur dire la vérité en décembre une
étude menée par l'institut sapiens effet
paru révélant une perte de confiance de
la population envers les scientifiques
en cause un phénomène de brouillage qu
olivier babeau président de l'institut
avait lié à je cite la multiplication
des médias des contenus et des
interprétations
cette diversité d'opinion bien sûr à
défier l'idéal de ce qu'on appelle le
consensus scientifique ou la communauté
scientifique mais ce phénomène de
brouillage ne provient très t-il pas
qu'un peu tout les scientifiques
spécialistes ou pas ont donné leur avis
sur le co vide
en effet de nombreux médecins sont
invités comme référence sur la copie de
19 alors qu'ils ne sont pas forcément
des spécialistes de la maladie
on pense à gilbert de ray par exemple
chef de service néphrologie à la pitié
salpêtrière
ce spécialiste des reins donc a pu
appeler comme certains de ses collègues
à déconfinement plus dur et plus précoce
est bien légitime
c'est un débat normalement les personnes
spécialistes des sujets comme le
confinement sont les épidémiologistes où
les expert en politique de santé
publique comme martin blachier ou jean
françois toussaint
en dehors de ces experts s'exprimer sur
ce sujet peut donc tenir de ce qu'on
appelle l'ultra crépy d'ariane isme ce
mot monstrueux qui semblent tout droit
sortis de mary poppins signifie un
comportement qui consiste à donner son
avis sur des sujets à propos desquels on
n'a pas de compétence crédible démontré
une spécialité des plateaux télé pendant
cette crise s'exprimer sur la copie de
19 et pourtant très délicat puisque même
entre spécialistes
on n'est pas toujours d'accord on a été
étonné de voir la forme que prenaient
les cas cliniques et l'épidémie depuis
juillet
et dès le départ on a trouvé un mutant
qu'on a appelée marseille ce matin on
nous a dit qu'il semblait que le virus
ne mute et pas le virus n'a pas muté et
est exactement le même
les souches qui circulent en france sont
celles qui circulaient en mars et avril
alors là on ne comprend plus karine
lacombe et médecins infectiologues et
spécialiste de lakovic 19
comment at-elle pu se tromper sur un
sujet aussi criants et bien parce que la
recherche c'est un peu comme dans le
sport tout le monde n'est pas égal dans
sa discipline et pour départager les
meilleurs spécialistes des autres il
existe un indicateur qui s'appelle le
achille bex
cette notation est calculé à partir du
nombre de citations que le travail d'un
scientifique génère par sa notoriété
plus on est cité plus on est crédible
plus le achille bex est élevé et parmi
nos scientifiques star ii plateaux télé
tout le monde n'est pas égal devant la
chine d'aix philippe froguel par exemple
que vous avez pu voir sur nos plateaux
et leurs titulaires d'un achim dext 171
plus ce qui fait de lui l'un des
médecins français les plus célèbres à
l'international de même pour le
fulminant didier raoult qui tient une
cote à plus de 180 à titre de
comparaison
côté conseil scientifique on est moins
connu arnaud fontanes et culmine à
achille bex 2 36 k reen lacombe à 37
yazdan yazdanpanah 52 et le virologue
bruno lina 55 pas beaucoup de stars de
la science donc à l'exception de la
grande épidémiologistes dominique
costagliola qui affiche un sérieux 96
bien sûr cette notation est discutable
mais comme le faisait remarquer philippe
froguel l'autre jour en paraphrasant
churchill
elle est la pire à l'exception de tous
les autres dans l'index des chercheurs
hautement cité qui référence tous les
scientifiques qui ont achille bex au
dessus de 100 il faut beaucoup chercher
pour trouver les noms de scientifiques
français et il ne figure aucun des
membres de l'actuel conseil scientifique
de là à penser que ça explique nos
mauvaises performances dans la crise du
coc vide il n'y a qu'un pas